all right so we'll go over the opening
onot okay
um let's get
some uh let's say this the energetic and
the spiritual aspects of the art are not
going to
violate the physical aspects of the art
and the physical aspects thereby will
not violate Material Science that
they're not going to okay if you you
Mystics out there are you more
mystically
inclined if you fast forward with that
reasoning
mysticism or the reconciliation of the
subject object dichotomy and all that is
required as a prerequisite in reasoning
for that possibility is
not antithetical to reasoning it it is
the ultimate reasoning
okay all right so we're going to look at
this at the physical level but we are
wanting to understand that if we have a
sound physical level to this technique
then and only then will we have a sound
energetic aspect and thereby a sound
spiritual aspect to it
okay so um um to remember what our
spiritual component is it's a
Reconciliation of dichotomy okay um
which we simplify because of all else
that is noted when we talk about the
energetic component or the physical
component at the spiritual component we
simplify the reconciliation of all
dichotomy by referring to the
reconciliation of two types of
experience of the world or two types of
mind okay all we want to take out of
that is we're looking for reconciliation
of
dichotomy in Silk Road cultures the way
that dichotomy is
reconciled is in a spiraling rotation or
as we say here a spiral rotating cross
and this is the only way that you'll
reconcile those two minds those two
experiences of the world this is the
only way you'll reconcile yin and
yang Yin and yangong
Chi K and II it's the only way you can
do it and when you are uh sound in your
thinking or your reason at the spiritual
level and at the energetic level it must
be reflected in your physical level so
if the only way I can do this is with a
spiraling rotating
cross then my eal must consist of a
spiral
rotation of two axes just it has
to I can't be uh for example going one
way I pull one way and then I push back
that way I can't do that I can't go one
way push back and do
zigzags that's not going to
work my technique must do
this or
this T to
okay and this means then because of the
concentric Reon reasoning even at the
physical level that not only must ID
move in a spiral of some kind now I
must we
must our bodies must our hands must our
arms must my tanden
must
okay so we want to note
that we don't want want these zigzagging
reversing angles because they do not
function energetically and thereby they
do not function spiritually but also
they're not martially sound they don't
work
okay so let's get into the physical and
as we complete our physical analysis of
eel you will see the spiral as I just
described it
okay there's a first there's a there's
two Marshall principles we want to start
with because we're looking at the
opening of e and they were given
before we have
angle of
deviation
and
angle
of
deflection
these two angles are going to tell me
where to move and how to move so they're
going to tell
me
my
oaki in my angle
deviation and my tabaki in my angle
deflection because there's a
rule these are in a a contrary
relationship to each other that's the
rule of angle deviation and angle
deflection meaning if I deviate to the
right I deflect to the
left if I deviate to the left I deflect
to the right never ever ever will I
deviate to the right and deflect to the
right it is impossible going back to the
spiral talk
if I move my body and my hand like this
I can't get any rotation started but if
I'm moving in one way and my hand is
moving in the other way now I can start
I am controlling the two ends of the
movement and I can start rotating them
if I'm going in one way and I only
control one end of the lever all I can
do is go back in the exactly the same
path and you'll see that that's what
most people people do
okay that's the energetic reason but the
Marshal reason is this your first
movement is already a manifestation of
non-c contestation so if I'm the
target I don't want to remain the Target
because then they Remain the attacker I
remain in an oppositional relationship
to them I have a dichotomy and it's not
going
away what I want to do instead is not be
the target so how do you do that don't
stay where the target was stain move
your body in other words if you're not
there to be hit they can't hit you
that's your angle of
deviation to ensure that you are not
tracked by the attacker so you as the
target are not tracked you deflect in
the opposite
angle that way you remain truly in the
angle of
deviation if I deviate to the right and
I deflect to the right I did not
actually deviate I remain the
Target and I'll show you that
now okay so the way that I was taught uh
from cha Sensei violated this rule of
angle deviation and angle of
deflection uh if he was grabbing in
gak I would deviate to my right and I
would also deflect to my right so this
is going to be new to you
just keep keep push keep your grip okay
so I go this way and then I bring him
with me you
see and depending on your UK you got one
or two
reactions so one was the one that you
did where I kind of keep it out and then
I make you
fall and then as you come up we pretty
much
Start EO from there okay in my mind
that's not a Keon that's a what if what
if you did
Su the guy kept his grip and got back up
then it would open up EO okay and in
that way if it's already telling you
where EO should start it should start
with
energy going past you to the left do do
you see that okay all right the other
option is this person neutralizes the
weight here and gets under it straight
ahead you see so as he
goes out and he pulls out that way he
comes this way okay which which anyone
could do because you're moving to your
left and deflecting to your left okay
it's no different than then if you throw
a punch and I'm going to deviate to my
right and deflect to my right then the
line of attack is going to stay with me
okay if I go right this hand has to go
to the left then it's not tracking me
okay so uh and this is this is
interesting because in cha Sensei
lineage it wasn't called the what if but
we're going to call it the what if the
what if they get up from sum Tosh while
they're still grabbing you no one really
ever did it for Tachi was they did the
first version so the the first version
he goes out and he deflects that way and
they stop here they just stop there okay
they you have to train yourself as a UK
in a way not to
fall into
sumos and also don't crash into me you
see so as you go really hard you're
going really hard oh bad UK all right I
have to figure out he goes really hard
and I have to figure out how to stop
where you can see I could still go
forward because he's not deflecting in
contrary angle to his angle deviation
they're complimentary angles so you're
still open to it okay so we don't want
to do that all
right so if we
look at the working what if if I go this
way and I take you down and just s your
touch and as you're coming
up you can see that my I'm on the right
and I'm going to deflect to the left you
see that well we just want to do that
from the start okay and the way to do
that is instead of going this way with
your deflection your deflection goes
this
way so right on the grab not this
way right on the grab I go to the right
my hand and his elbow go to the
left just like if you threw a punch I
move to the right or my parry and blocks
go to the left
here he is I go to the right he goes to
the
left if we're standing if we're standing
and he does not do the what if but you
better do the goody K me it don't crash
into me okay he's at this
angle he's not at that angle and that's
why all I can do because all I'm
controlling is one end of the lever all
I can do is go back back on that same
lever which is what you see and this is
a straight line I move on a straight
line you moved on a straight
line but we don't want a straight line
so I going start this rotating and now
he goes that
[Music]
way
so now why do I say that's rotating it
looks like he's kind of going straight
well he's going around me on the other
one he's coming into
me on this one he's going I'm in the
middle he's going around me and he's
still going around
me now when you try to get someone who's
used to the old way to do this new new
way they think it's just a freefor all
so they combine the two you see maybe
they go
here and it's not quite around
me
or they don't move at
all there was a deviation it might be
small so here my rear leg did it then my
front
leg or maybe my whole body does
it and the angle of deflection is made
smaller but I have to
generate this spiralis and that means
I'm at the center okay that's the way
you generate
spirals all
right the second mistake that people
often make is they don't let the spiral
get past you they get Ang anxious so
they go one and they try to turn it and
so we'll do it on the other
side and just like in all of viito you
have my and my means uh space time not
just space so there's a time for this
spiral rotation okay so as I go one way
he goes the other way I don't start
doing the second spiral
until my inward spiral of my Tachi will
feed the spiral in action and in order
for that to happen his shoulder must be
past the grab okay from where I'm
looking now not not past the grab that's
going to be way late from the original
plane the plane that we're on is
starting to rotate okay so if his
shoulder is on that side and I do my
power rotation I don't get as much of
you in that deep
curve so I have to let your shoulder go
by there it is and now I can do
it it goes by it pass me that's when
this comes
[Music]
in
and that point becomes even more
relevant because as you're standing you
have to have bigger movements okay so I
have to let his shoulder go by it's by
now now I can do
it I can't be on the front and try to do
it he has to go
by we can't really throw him into the
wall but we'll do it gently
I go one way past me past me and now I
can do
it one way past me now I can do
it all right and
now that he we start this relationship
of him moving around
me I am going to take this this spiral
but and this is why I call a spiral
rotating it's going to travel it's more
like a corkscrew roller coaster that's
also spitting on the tracks itself that
is what I want okay so on the first amot
I'm going to go inside the spiral here
you see and then continue the spiral to
here
this is where the EDI
ends if we do the other one and don't
just be a good G don't crash into me and
I go
here this just pushes him ahead of me
you see and apparently he's supposed to
do that but usually no one does they
don't lay down to the a but you can see
on the good UK that he just
is a straight line and I'm just a
straight line people just keep doing
this because this is a cork
screwing
gyroscopic roller
coaster I don't want to be in a
two-dimensional plane where I'm on one
side and just pushing something ahead of
me I'm going to eventually spiry will
rotate it so that I get on top because
if you pay attention I'm currently on
the bottom and I'm going to eventually
get on top of this which is what you
want for a
pin so let me give you a clock principle
so you understand how we're moving
12:00 6 3 and N9 deviate to 9 deflect to
three let his shoulder go past you start
bringing him to eight step inside that
spiral and bring him all the way around
to
10 that's the Emi that you have and then
the technique would finish with one
more
again let him posture in he go step
inside bring him around around to the
other
corner I go to nine he goes to three I'm
throwing towards eight I step inside and
I bring him around the 10 there's your
Ed me then technique finishes
here
now try it I guess thank
you just
see
make him come around
you come around you no no no but it's
not Ur
hi there you
go
no we're not finishing it we're just
doing the
adashi so keep the hand up stay in h
me on me there you go
shoulder pass good bring them around
good hand
up
[Music]
don't bring him around stay in on
me
hey another angle we mentioned in the
lecture on the Sciences is angle
cancellation and so when he grabs that's
that angle that way okay on that
shoulder so I don't want to ever pull
this way cuz the other hand is coming at
me okay protect
yourself this goes this way to knock
that shoulder BL
not here Bo this is at best iuchi only
he has the energy going with his strike
and I
don't this one not I I hit he doesn't
hit this is creating your angle
cancellation what the is that what
again
Bo and this movement that we're doing is
your front inward kazushi that you're
doing
so this
way front inward
Kaz Ang go constellation with the
deflection and deviation front inward
position the spiral that I'm generating
Marley again is tightening up his
shoulder
joint so I'm going to rip it off
okay as I come
around this joint The Joint not his
elbow is going to keep
tightening as I do no different movement
than I than you ever do it's just now on
a spiral pattern so as I come
around
down as I move around nobody no UK
should ever let you move around without
you now having to loosen it okay so as I
come around now here's where he'll feel
it tap when you don't like it like so I
can't get to here without letting him
out I'll try at a different
angle and as I rotate
now this angle as I go back around cuz
I'm going to spiral it's going to be
really tight cuz it's already tighten
out like you could already do the top
from here because I use a spiral to
tighten up all the joint so now as I
move into it I'm never going to get
there meaning if I was holding it just
as tight this is where I break his arm
into the final pin
whereas in the other technique other
hand other
hand and I'm pushing just do your cing
grab grab
grab
[Music]
boom there's no stress on the
joint
[Music]
right because there's no
stress the theory is is that I'm going
to hold him down and he's going to be
pinned but we already know that he can
do a grany roll from there okay he can
just roll out of that he can slide
forward and take away the pressure the
vertical pressure point um this is not a
pin could be a break though it could be
a dislocation if it's done properly on a
spiral okay the other thing that I have
is again
internally so my tanden is moving one
way and as it goes another way it now
has to go down so it's going down it's
coming back up and going back
around and now it finishes down over the
top and now I do all that going in the
other direction in this movement here so
it's going
down I'll loosen it for him is going
down
around back around and
down on that one last movement none of
that is in the other technique that has
no angle of cancellation on the
cross-lateral arm that does not generate
kazushi as in the
forward inward kazushi pattern generates
no angle
consolation and works on a linear line
requiring your UK to be good by
following the
choreography totally
different all right you guys try the
whole P don't grab me with those weak
ass ribs every time you grab me protect
yourself otherwise I have to hit you
until it becomes Instinct you get it and
it shouldn't be that you should be
disciplined enough that's how I was told
to grab so that's how I grab do you
understand